il y a un sujet et pour le modem parce
que vous dites majorité oui pour le
modem il y a toujours eu
une volonté de revoir le système
pour améliorer équilibre mais avant tout
aussi pour une meilleure justice qui
n'est pas cas pour un certain nombre de
personnes concernées je pense aux femmes
je pense aux carrière hachées je pense à
la question de la pilule notamment en
carrière longue donc c'est comme ça que
nous au sein de la majorité si vous
voulez on envisage le sujet
effectivement oui mais c'est quand même
aussi important de le dire
et après et après il y a une question
qui se pose sur lequel il faut vous
dites urgence nous on a demandé François
Bayrou vous le savez très bien en
septembre c'est battu qu'on est
justement le temps de la concertation il
faut le prendre ce temps là il l'a
demandé il a obtenu et la concertation
s'est engagée à partir du mois octobre
elle n'est pas terminée
nous n'avons pas encore de contour enfin
on a des grandes des grandes lignes sur
lesquelles il faut encore je pense et
nous pensons travailler notamment la
question de la pénibilité on écoute et
on écoute et on entend ce que dit
Laurent Berger et ça nous semble
important notamment sur cette question
de la pénibilité et puis après
évidemment il y a une question de
pérennité du système de répartition
auxquelles nous sommes attachés
c'est-à-dire dans un pays où avec cette
baisse démocratique les actifs cotisent
et payent pour les pour les retraités il
faut retrouver un équilibre sur une
dizaine d'années nous sommes évidemment
conscients de ça se mettre d'accord
aussi sur les bons chiffres donc voyez
il y a beaucoup de nous qui seront pas
mal de questions encore qui doit faire
les efforts
oui vous parlez de catégorie il y a
effectivement je reviens sur ce que
disait monsieur Arenas effectivement un
problème en France qui est l'emploi des
seniors qui est le taux de chômage de
58% des plus de 55 ans et donc demandé
et avoir une mesure d'âge nous
particulièrement trouvons cela un peu
compliqué nous n'y avons jamais été
favorablement très enthousiaste à l'idée
de faire partir
la formule qui qui nous convient en
revanche l'allongement ou l'accélération
d'une réforme qui est déjà été votée
sous le précédent quinquennat je parle
celui d'avant c'est-à-dire la réforme
Touraine l'accélération la réforme
torale c'est-à-dire l'allongement de la
durée de cotisation en excluant
évidemment un certain nombre de
catégories en prenant compte de l'usure
professionnelle en tenant compte des
carrières longues en tenant compte des
cariérarchies et des femmes ça ça veut
dire qu'il faut se mettre autour de la
table et en parler mais choisir aussi
qui parce que quand vous parlez
il faut poursuivre cette discussion et
dans un esprit quand même de dialogue je
veux bien il y a les chiffres il y a la
pérennité du système on connaît les
enjeux il faut se donner le temps on a
entendu la Premier ministre la première
ministre parler d'une dizaine d'années
ok maintenant il faut aussi voir moi je
pense qu'il faut apporter des des
solutions à ces travailleurs qui se
trouvent où c'est où ces personnes ou
ces métiers qui sont en difficulté et
sur lequel c'est impossible d'entendre
un allongement du départ de la date de
départ à retraite c'est impossible pour
une personnalité
mais bien sûr c'est pour ça que je pose
cette question qui dans ce cas-là doit
consentir davantage d'efforts pour ceux
qui en ont plus besoin comme l'autre
d'ailleurs Rodrigo Arenas comme Isabelle
Floren quand vous écoutez histoire de
Didier vous dites ça fait partie des
gens à qui on doit permettre de partir
plus tôt à la retraite Isabelle Florian
évidemment évidemment je veux dire à 16
ans travail physique et se retrouver
donc dans un dispositif où il devra
allonger bon là il y a des il y a des
critères à prendre en compte évidemment
et
Monsieur en fait partie pour moi c'est à
dispositif déjà de carrière longue qui
doit s'appliquer donc c'est ça que nous
demandons il y a différentes choses qui
ont été annoncées par le gouvernement
sur lequel j'espère que nous allons
aussi pouvoir travailler c'est les c'est
les cessations progressives d'activité
pour les personnes plus
seniors dans l'entreprise et les cumules
emploi retraite également donc ça c'est
des c'est des annonces qui ont été
faites en tout cas on entend des
précisions moi je pense que ça ça va
dans le bon sens la France est quand
même en retard sur le taux d'emploi des
seniors et on sait bien que si on permet
ces cotisations supplémentaires rien que
de 10 points c'est les économistes qui
le disent ils ont Hervé Lorenzi le dit
très bien on résout une partie du déf
annoncé 12 milliards des retraites
que nous avons enfin moi c'est toujours
pareil je crois les chiffres je regarde
les chiffres du corps et sur cette base
là on lit aussi les prévisions et les
solutions apportées par les économistes
je veux revenir juste sur la question du
dialogue social parce que je crois qu'on
est engagé sur ces sujets là et le
dialogue social en France
malheureusement je crois qu'il faut
qu'on retrouve cette culture pour
avancer en dehors même de l'affrontement
perpétuel qu'on connaît sur un certain
nombre de sujets on le dit toujours
on se retrouve à manifester et à voter
l'un contre l'autre à l'Assemblée
nationale quelle que soit la majorité
d'ailleurs oui enfin on dit toujours je
pense qu'on peut aussi évoluer le
dialogue ça ça
implique de la confiance de la confiance
et des engagements et de la conscience
vous entendez ce que disait monsieur il
dit on a quand même au début de son
intervention un problème un peu de
confiance et ça on le sait donc je veux
dire travaillons là dessus moi je pense
que cette visite elle est importante
elle est importante pour les relations
avec un évidemment
une grande puissance
importante sur beaucoup de sujets
notamment sur la question
environnementale aussi alors
effectivement vous dites quels résultats
c'est l'agenda montrer l'agenda caché
quelque part de ce qui est important de
la délégation qui est venue aussi avec
le président non seulement politique
mais évidemment en d'entreprises donc là
il y a des relations qui devaient être
réchauffé entre guillemets on a connu
l'étape Trump et les difficultés et là
maintenant on est rentré dans une
nouvelle phase et tant mieux pour la
France mais je dirais surtout tant mieux
pour l'Europe parce qu'on sait très bien
que derrière ça le président français
tant mieux pour nous c'est lui qui fait
cette première visite c'est que c'est
une visite officielle d'importance avec
renfort de communication qui me semble
quand même une bonne chose mais derrière
ça on sait très bien que l'enjeu de de
cette visite c'est d'être fort aussi au
niveau européen pour résister à ce que
vous décrivez très bien qui est la
concurrence mondiale par rapport à
l'attractivité économique par rapport
aux implantations d'entreprises et là on
sait très bien que les États-Unis sont
rentrés dans une campagne offensive
d'attractivité le président de l'a dit
quand même déjà commencé avec Donald
Trump qui avait déjà commencé il a redit
il faut conforter ce qu'on peut
conforter il faut dire aussi des choses
on verra bien
devant les chefs d'entreprise
il y a une agressivité américaine il a
dit que les choix américains étaient
faits pour fragmenter l'Occident malgré
ça des Américains n'ont pas bougé d'un
seul iota
écoutez on verra on verra quelle est la
possibilité à moyen terme
justement par rapport à ces assez
facilité d'implantation qui sont données
effectivement on peut s'interroger quand
on lit le chiffre de certaines des
localisations envisagées par des groupes
européens qui soient italien allemand
qui bénéficient d'une condition
d'attraction sur le territoire américain
complètement
alors que nous n'arrivons à peine à
faire du 3 ou du 10% sur le territoire
européen il faut se poser des questions
certaines entreprises en parlent là le
président avec les moyens qu'à la France
c'est assez réduit mais avec les moyens
de l'Europe avec les moyens de l'Europe
ça implique et c'est le travail
notamment de la commissaire weinsteiger
de pouvoir consolider et de pouvoir se
mettre d'accord au niveau européen pour
être concurrentiel face à cette
agressivité en essayant de d'accord à 26
ce qui n'est pas toujours facile mais
nous avons eu des nous avons eu des
succès quand même sur sur des prises en
compte et des mutualisations et